now that winter weather is still causing
problems at airports all across the
country and in particular Southwest
Airlines this morning its CEO told the
Wall Street Journal the company's only
flying a third of its Fleet today and
Southwest is Reed International
Airport's busiest carrier Candace
Charles is live from the airport this
morning with a look at how things are
looking Candace good morning to you
good morning John good morning folks now
this is the Southwest baggage line as
you can see this line doesn't look crazy
but if you look over here you can see
just how extensive the damage is really
and just speaking to some of the folks
here it really is quite a sad situation
we heard that some people were even
crying upstairs one man told me that he
had four cancellations and it was
because there was no pilot now we've
been hearing about weather issues but it
sounds like we're also hearing about
pilot issues I have a night here from
New York thank you for joining us tell
us a little bit about your journey your
travels she's actually coming here just
to enjoy she wasn't here with family so
I came here the 22nd everything was good
except for my mother I was able to get
my luggage but my mom had a separate
flight they got their luggage yesterday
so that was about four days
and now our flights got canceled so my
mom doesn't leave to the 31st I don't
leave till the 29th no hotel vouchers no
meal vouchers
we're on our own that is just crazy that
there's no hotel vouchers or anything
like that so what are you guys planning
to do I did hear that they may give you
vouchers for your clothes because they
told you to buy your own clothes yeah
but this is the thing it's after you pay
everything so right now we're actually
waiting for the supervisor because if
it's over 300 which since it's a bit
it's been well over 400 uh 300
um they're going to wait for the
supervisor and maybe cut a check for us
but as far as everything else we got to
just figure it out now I know you say
you don't really ride Southwest that
often how do you feel about going back
on now and really what else did you see
from other folks that were getting on
their flights oh it's bad I do know I
don't even want to fly with Southwest
ever again my mother's saying the same
thing we actually have a a flight in
Miami soon we don't even want to take
that flight but yeah I'm so sorry you
guys hopefully you guys will get home
and soon hopefully get some rest while
you're here places you take careful take
slow and give yourself some Grace thank
you for chatting with us I really
appreciate it you guys it really is
quite a situation here and as John
mentioned this may be only the beginning
you guys we're gonna stick with you guys
here on air online on social with the
latest a few tips for you really quickly
if you do have to come to the airport
please check Harry International to see
what it may be maybe at the late
cancellation if you do have to come make
sure that you have some of your
belongings with you on your person
because you may be stuck in the airport
for now live from Harry International
I'm Candace Charles 8 news now Candice
yeah very frustrating situation thanks
for the update appreciate that